okay i guess i should say although maybe
i don't need to that this
segment is not a politically correct
segment um
if you've been watching this program for
a while you know that political
correctness has never been
really a priority uh of mine and
those that are in the so-called realist
movements are going to know what i mean
sometimes you've got to call things what
they are
uh and sometimes you have to realize
that what you believe to be an accurate
representation of the world
simply isn't and what i'm talking about
is that there are
all sorts of um really smart pieces all
over the place
about what's happening to our country
what's happening in the united states
right now
under uh trump's america you have
american writers
and foreign writers who are trying to
sort of figure out
what exactly has led to this trumpian
america status quo in which we find
ourselves
during the year 2019 how can people
be so gullible some writers have
ascribed this to
fear of losing status real or perceived
influenced people into voting for donald
trump in 2016. and yeah that is part of
it
others have ascribed to racism and
xenophobia
the motivation to vote for someone like
donald trump and of course that's a part
of it for sure i can't deny that
we've seen people like dilbert creator
scott adams say that it's donald trump's
skills at
persuasion and influence even if he
doesn't get every policy
uh trump's persuasion skills influenced
a lot of people to vote for him and yeah
okay that's part of it you have
the hillary was a bad candidate angle
and yeah okay that was part of it
but that doesn't explain why trump today
maintains an approval rating in the high
30s or low 40s depending on where and
when you look
we've heard the meme of tribalism and
partisanship
cited as why we have so many people
who support trump despite being an
obvious liar in terms of what he will do
and not really even understanding the
policies that he espoused
that's also part of it but we are not
going to
get beyond the situation in which we
find ourselves today
until we admit that there are just lots
of dumb people
and some of them vote and they don't
understand anything and they're not
going to understand anything so that a
solution to the current problem is going
to require
uh um it's going to have to be a
solution that doesn't include them
all right part of its cultural that's
just a reality
part of it is a class issue part of it
is because
education and thinking itself have been
stigmatized and smeared as liberal
nonsense i'll give you some examples
trump's trade bloviating um if you
believe a con man who knows nothing
about trade
that he's going to fix the problem and
eliminate the trade deficit
and then you see the numbers that the
trade deficit is
up despite all of his negotiations and
the tariffs and everything else
at a certain point a person who is
informed and capable of critical
thinking says you know what
uh he lied and he's a con man and i
can't support him anymore
uh the tax cuts for middle america we
were told everybody's everybody's
getting a tax cut and now you have as i
told you last week
republicans furious on twitter about
what they see as tax increases some of
them are actually tax increases because
they were duped
others don't understand that your refund
doesn't actually tell you what your
total tax liability was
it's because they're just not
knowledgeable and we're not going to be
able to inform them we're going to have
to find a solution
that doesn't include these people uh
trump building a wall with mexico that
mexico will pay for
that was never going to happen right
there was never going to be a wall built
across the u.s mexico border that mexico
was going to pay for
and it's also clear according to
engineers as we looked at in detail two
weeks ago that there's not going to be a
wall built
period across the entire u.s mexico
border during donald trump's presidency
whether it goes on two more years or six
more years
the best case scenario for a wall
builder
is that trump will get a few billion for
some tiny portion of it period it would
take a decade or more even if we started
now
to do what trump wants to do and we
don't even have the money for it at this
point so it's not happening
but you have trumpists who continue
believing it
either because of cognitive dissonance
or as i'm increasingly convinced
simply ignorance um believing in the
idea
of tax cuts for the rich as good for the
country
we saw that the tax cuts for the rich uh
under reagan
the tax cuts for the rich under trump
didn't work and raised the deficit
and the exact same thing is happening
under donald trump at a certain point
you have to say it's not just tribalism
it's also ignorance
when you have a system that makes it
easier to get a gun
than to drive a car this is simply
inconceivable in most developed
countries
the world is aghast at this but there's
a bunch of people who are just
not smart enough to realize how crazy it
is
and then on top of this you have to drop
the vicious cycle
of right wing media like fox news people
watch fox news
because they believe that no one other
than fox news is telling them the truth
and then we know that the more you watch
fox news the less informed you are
even compared to watching no news at all
and it reinforces the idea that nobody
tells you the truth other than fox news
it's a circle of idiocy
now let me preempt what i know some of
you are going to say about the story
i will get emails and tweets from people
saying
uh david this is why trump won your
liberal arrogance
about trumpists being dumb is why trump
won and will win again
no sorry smart people aren't voting for
trump
because liberals say that they're dumb
on twitter right that's not the issue
this is why arguing with trumpists to
try to win elections is a loser's game
and why i am insisting it's it's
happening every other show at this point
that i'm reminding you
if we want to win in 2020 it's going to
happen
despite trumpists not because of them
because we've convinced them to change
their minds it's just not going to
happen
period uh and that's why get out the
votes
is the most important tactic
to take power back from this
administration
in twenty twenty uh tell me where i'm
going wrong i would love to hear from
you